- Getting rich is
fun in the future.
(loud poof)
- Oh.
Hey, Poppy.
- Satan, thank you so much
for being on my show.
- Are you able to
call this a show?
- Well, it's on the internet.
- Does that make it a show?
- Of course.
What a lovely set they've
provided you with.
- I brought you here to be
more famous on the internet.
- Well,
I have to say with billions
of loyal followers,
I am
just not getting the
comments and likes
that I would like to get.
- What do you mean by that?
- I feel like everyone
thinks I bought my followers.
- Did you?
- Yeah.
Well, some of them.
- Let's see, the first
thing you need to know
is that gaining
followers is easy.
- No, I'm listening.
- The second thing
you need to know
is that money can't
buy everything.
- But what content
really tests the best
with audiences in 2016?
- Just post a video of an
innocent person being murdered,
and enjoy the
advertising revenue.
- Praise Jesus!
Making money on the internet
is a beautiful thing!
- Satan, thank you so much
for being on myshow.